she showed me what real love is and show
me how to accept it Cara Delevingne
is spreading the love confirming her
relationship with Ashley Benson twice
this week first by posting this steamy
makeout video on Instagram with the
caption hashtag pride and again on
Monday night where she was honored at
the Trevor live gala in New York City
and had this to say in her speech I also
have a very not a special woman in this
room to thank and you know who you are
she is one of the people that helped me
love myself when I needed it most and I
really needed it she showed me what real
love is and show me how to accept it
which was a lot harder than I thought I
love you sprinkles sprinkles how cute is
that Ashley showed her support sharing a
clip from Cara speech on her instace
Tory writing love you Cara Delevingne
proud of you before taking the stage
Cara walked the orange carpet and opened
up about her decision to go public with
her relationship she explained to E news
that there were two big reasons one it
was pride and two it's been about a year
since they started dating
[Music]
but now it does with you huh Cora and
Ashley were first linked when they were
spotted kissing in August 2018 after
they shot the movie her smell together
these girls might be our salvation if
you don't or Peter them in the process
of drama
then fans notice that Ashley had been
wearing a necklace with their initials
on it since then Ashley has been
spending time with Cara's family and
they've attended several of the same
events together although they've mostly
been pictured separately
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]